nous observons des des changements de
comportement extrêmement fort
par exemple sur le domestique
c'est-à-dire quand il y a une
alternative en train ce qu'on a observé
poste covid par rapport à la fois
l'habitude de la visio c'est une chute
violente des trajets d'affaires des
trajets pour faire des allers-retours
journée je sais plus ils ont été divisés
par quasiment par deux les
allers-retours journée donc on le voit
sur nos navettes de d'Orly vers
Marseille tipito
on voit ça
on va voir mais c'est un peu plus
marginal des clients qui vont
je dirais faire des voyages plus longs
donc effectivement on voit moins de
baisse sur des séjours de plusieurs
jours etc ce qu'on voit également c'est
des clients entreprises qui dans le cas
de leur propre trajectoire svtiales de
décarbonation
par exemple acheter du SAF donc on leur
propose de
d'acheter des de négocier des contrats
de savent qu'on leur a loue et qui leur
permettent effectivement de
réduire il y a des systèmes je dirais
administratifs qui devrait fonctionner
de réduire lorsque 3 et les voyages de
leurs collaborateurs donc les deux
comportements qu'on voit fortement c'est
ça c'est quand on a une alternative des
carbonée on la prend pour les clients
pour motif personnel et les clients
corporate qui eux veulent s'engager et
veulent trouver des solutions pour les
voyages qui restent indispensables je
dirais pour leurs affaires sur le client
individuel je vous dira pas qu'on a pas
quelques clients qui parfois nous
achètent 100% de l'équivalent de leur
empreinte carbone en SAF on va la voir
on a eu récemment avec les premières
qu'il a fait on a mais reste très très
marginal est-ce que ça va devenir un
comportement je dirais majoritaire on
peut parler que de ce qu'on observe
comme le divincent ce qu'on observe
c'est quand même un retour fort des
voyages nous on est on a aujourd'hui
toutes les compagnies manquent d'avion
et pilotes par rapport à la demande qui
est revenue très fortement une demande
plus fortement loisirs donc le mix est
plutôt sur des voyages à dominant
personnel donc on l'observe et j'ai pas
de donc cette évolution et cette
aspiration à des voyages des carbonés
elle existait fortement mais elle le
fait pas baisser de ce que nous
observons aujourd'hui la demande donc la
question c'est vraiment comment on
répond à cette aspiration de voyage tout
en révision complètement nos process et
l'énergie qui est à la base des voyages
et permettant du coup un voyage des
carbonés voilà c'est ce que nous
observons aujourd'hui je vous aurais pas
dit ça il y a deux ans c'est pas ce
qu'on s'est dit pendant la crise covid
c'est pas ce qu'on a imaginé mais c'est
vraiment ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
très forte appétence pour le voyage de
plus en plus pour motif personnel et des
clients qui demandent une décarbonation
mais qui vont pas être prêt à payer je
dirais les sommes dont on vient de
parler